hello here steve kaufmann i am the
founder of link i talk
long eleven and my thoughts
on language learning and say i
will tell you a bit about how i
deal with languages and how to take advan
age of our site for l
nguage learning which  elik
first of all the most important point is
that in order to be able to learn languages
ve to love the language you have to do th
ngs that are pleasant you h
ve to have fun in le
rning and for me that tells you that
eans  listen and read things
that are interesting and things that
are not too difficult for me it
is not necessary to do
grammar exercises
it is not even necessary to
understand grammar explanations
I do not spend a lot of  time
studying my vocabulary
because what i like to do
is listen and read things which i
find interesting and enjoyable
is what we have done at linx that
we have facilitated the
learning from interesting content
so our system will ensure
that first you can choose what
interests you and you will be able to
choose content at a level that
roughly corresponds to your level
so that is not too difficult it
You don't have to speak all the
time to learn, but you
can speak with
native speakers of the
language you're learning
you can write and she's a member
of our community will correct
things that I had written written but
the most important thing is to
take pleasure in learning
so take the time to understand
our site
there are many functions that will
help you learn but above all
have fun  you and like this you will
be successful thank you very much goodbye